Director Steven Spielberg changed blockbuster
cinema forever in 1993 when he released the
dinosaur-resurrecting epic Jurassic Park,
which remains one of the most successful and
popular movies ever made.
The impressive cast included two unknown child
actors playing the forever-traumatized grandchildren
of the park's creator, Jon Hammond.
Decades after becoming famous for running
from raptors, and with the franchise still
roaring at five films and counting, where
are they now?
Ariana Richards
Now here's something that'll make you feel
super-old: as of the making of this video,
Ariana Richards is only one year younger than
Jeff Goldblum was when he began filming Jurassic
Park with Richards in 1992.
Richards was 12 when she played Lex Murphy,
a skilled young hacker … well, at least
by '90s cinematic standards …
"You got it?"
"Yes!"
Over the years, Richards shifted from acting
to painting, which is now her main professional
focus.
Shortly after Jurassic Park's release, Richards
sent Steven Spielberg a watercolor self-portrait
inspired by one of the scenes in the film.
The painting now hangs in Spielberg's office.
Along with her role as the pogo-stick-loving
Mindy Sterngood in the 1990 cult hit Tremors,
Richards' most well-known on-screen appearances
were in the Jurassic Park franchise.
In 1997, she briefly appeared in Jurassic
Park sequel The Lost World, and followed that
cameo with handful of TV movies over the years.
In 2015, she told People,
"If some great role or project finds me, absolutely
that could be a nice thing to do, for sure."
At the time of that interview, her latest
TV movie was 2013's Battledogs, which was
produced by The Asylum, the team behind the
Sharknado movies ... and she hasn't acted
since.
"Chew on this, mother!"
Richards did, however, make an appearance
at the June 2018 premiere of Jurassic World:
Fallen Kingdom, where she reunited with her
former co-star Jeff Goldblum.
Joseph Mazzello
Talk about friends in high places!
In a 2013 interview with People, Joseph Mazzello
revealed that Steven Spielberg helped him
get into the University of Southern California
by writing him a letter of recommendation.
Mazzello graduated with a degree in cinema
and television, but has also acted steadily
since becoming famous in Jurassic Park for
his role as the dino-loving Tim Murphy.
"Galluh- Gallimimus!"
His biggest post-Park roles include The Social
Network, in which he played the Harvard student
who inspired Mark Zuckerberg to add relationship
statuses to Facebook profiles, and a stint
in the HBO Emmy-winning miniseries, The Pacific.
In 2016, he made his directorial debut with
the sports comedy-drama Undrafted, starring
Chace Crawford, Jim Belushi, and Mazzello
himself.
The film is based on Mazzello's brother, a
college baseball star who was scouted to play
in the majors, but ultimately didn't make
the cut.
Mazzello will next appear as Queen's bass
player John Deacon in Bryan Singer's Freddie
Mercury bio-pic Bohemian Rhapsody, which began
filming in September 2017.
When filming wrapped in January 2018, he tweeted:
"I'm sad.
Every moment was a pleasure.
Every day was a blessing.
One of the all time great experiences of my
life."
And that's saying a lot, considering his iconic
role in one of the most celebrated motion
pictures ever made.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!